and welcome back to another exciting
episode of the careful boys hey yo
careful boys but unfortunately this is
probably the last time we're going to
see steve because this gone man what the
[ __ ] i'm not happy about it i'm not
happy about it well i am happy right now
you're happy dude
i'm leaving jk where are you going i'll
probably be the only person that has the
balls to leave jk in the room
leave green dude
but i am leaving jk forever yeah i'm not
where are you going i'm going to las
vegas nevada whoa i heard that place is
cool can't carpool with bart why the
[ __ ] is your voice
oh no dude can't house pool with bart
you can't like carpool with bart when he
comes back dude bart's in the view
audience apparently
this guy loves the view man he's a big
big fan
whoopi goldberg
let's talk about that we'll take jk to
you then we'll take it i'll be fine so
then you can't solve my problems you
can't [ __ ] leave jay gabriel
yeah okay we're gonna take it over there
did you know you could buy one of the
places uh in trump tower
really are you like like a lot of the
casinos there's like a couple of floors
that are reserved for you to buy and
then so you could actually buy like a
house or apartment in there and you
could utilize the front desk as your
concierge and now people are going to
really think i'm a trump supporter
because i live in trump towers the
weirdest thing and i support his real
estate business adventure but imagine
the next jk studio in san francisco just
because it's trump tower how about bars
or any tower they really think jk's
according to you live from jk news at
trump tower
you always got a man
i hope they don't think i'm a trump guy
when i'm eating trump's steak in trump
tower who would have read maga hat you
know like the tip of the [ __ ] pyramid
thing well do it at this [ __ ] sphinx
land if you box or if you buy a house or
or
a room at the trump towers do you think
you get trump merch like for free i
think you ought to be able to get eggs
thrown at you
everybody hates me i've never set foot
in the trunk tower me neither did you
know there's a trump hotel in hawaii
yeah i'd say they're empty is it nice it
was really nice yeah i didn't even i
don't even know where it is it was like
really nice what's wrong with that
at trump tower well people don't want to
support trump right because they don't
like them so i mean i was back in the
day though i did a um so when i was
proposing nikki right i did one of those
uh what was that site where you like
plug in what you want and they just rate
mypooh.com uh no it wasn't about reading
my own [ __ ] thank you though
it's like where you punch in like what
you want and you want the like level of
stars for the hotel and then it just
picks it for you expedia or something
yeah it was that and and so i just
wanted the deal but like for like the
maximum amount of stars and all that
[ __ ] and it picked trump waikiki beach
and i was like sure [ __ ] who cares
yeah and this was like just before the
2016 primary and [ __ ] yeah it's like
we're just staying at the [ __ ] trump
and like it was really beautiful i
thought you're gonna lie about it where
is it i never stayed there it's waikiki
beach
are you ready
yeah no what the [ __ ]
no uh
i literally just raidmapu.com was an old
website where you would literally rate
pooh yeah i remember that you could take
a [ __ ] and like i think there's irony i
just think i just think that i'm [ __ ] i
joked around i was like really calm i
clicked in it and it actually this is
the home page oh [ __ ] oh really
that's funnier the iron is funny
right when you said it too i was like
here comes anthony with some
non-sequoia whatever
whatever
he's so let down the [ __ ] that was
pretty crazy stay in waikiki beach and
then i got like notoriously insanely
sunburned because the trump hotel gave
me like um like suntan lotion yeah so i
was like i don't have something in
lotion it's all orange i was like
yeah i was like where do i go to buy
something those are like oh we have some
here you go sir and like i literally put
it on and like in 30 minutes i'm already
burning alive it's probably made out of
water
it's just hand lotion so that night i
proposed nicki but i'm like a [ __ ]
red lobster
i love that restaurant yeah and like you
know like you probably you know you
pretty much want to [ __ ] after you do
that but like i was like don't touch me
[ __ ] like don't [ __ ] touch me
like it's you're saying put that cooling
aloe vera on me please exactly did you
know it was coming uh then this is
what's unfortunate about women oh [ __ ]
finally let's hear it geez they [ __ ]
they [ __ ] know they she knew for like
months and she even told her mom this
was so [ __ ] annoying well you knew
the day and everything oh yeah no i knew
exactly when i was gonna do it and where
right so we flew into hawaii i had the
ring for like nine months i bought it
like almost a year in advance and then
it got sent to me three months later
because i had a design ship and then
these cats sent to me and then i put it
in this bucket that i used to use to
remove ingrown toenails so i'm like
nikki's never gonna check this bucket
there's a specific do you have a lot of
ingrown toenail problems i suck for some
reason at cutting my toenails so i
always get ingrown toenails so i always
have to seriously remove them why are
you collecting them though you're a
podiatrist i'm not collecting in the
wedding ring bucket obviously that's why
you put it in that bucket so that's [ __ ]
it to soak my foot with salt so that i
can soften it so i can remove it that is
the move though that i thought it was a
bucket full of ingrown doesn't listen to
my feelings
no so so that's so that's what i used to
use is this red bucket and then nikki
would i used to put it above the fridge
and like i knew she would never look in
there so i put the ring like in a box
like in the middle of that bucket and
she never saw it no she never saw it but
she told her mom like i don't know two
months before we went there and i told
her dad i asked for permission from her
dad you think he [ __ ] blurted it out
no way no way no way i know he didn't i
know he didn't he blurts out it's in the
[ __ ] ingrown toenail bucket no he
looks good her old man
and me have a have a really cool thing
i'm the only guy that he ever liked that
nikki brought home apparently because he
says that to me and she says that to me
but but he also um
he wanted me to ask permission which is
interesting because my father i was like
yeah i'm gonna ask for nikki's dad like
nikki's dad for permission my my
father's like why would you do that
you're
no my old man was like uh he's like yeah
why would you do that because then if he
says no then that sucks and i'm like no
if he says no i want to know what the
[ __ ] problem is so i can fix it so yo
what's the problem so we can have a nice
time and a nice wedding because it is
the joining of two families yeah your
dad's like you're the problem
my dad's like i know you it'll never
work no i know you yeah if only but no
but um yeah so i i proposed to nikki at
waikiki
i got down on one knee i'll never forget
the rest of my life
and uh yeah i took but the worst thing
about it is i thought i surprised her
and then she tells me i told my mom two
months ago you're proposing in hawaii i
knew already she said that before you
were on your knee i don't know does that
mean
she told me a week after i did it oh we
were back at home oh what a sweetheart
it's an entertainer
you were probably sweating the whole
time bro
i was freezing my [ __ ] how nervous were
you imagine he's like he's like she's
like oh dude i told my mom too much
i do it i do it
i had a straight up out of body
experience yes
i did too yeah did you [ __ ] propose
in hawaii too no i did it in uh malibu a
point by the beach bro
outside yourself right yeah well i was
walking up and your boy this is why i
keep a fanny pack dog i had the ring
right here don't [ __ ] you avoid me
dude you know what i mean you in that
outfit too short shorts outfit in this
outfit in a case
yeah yeah my [ __ ] toenail bucket case
so we're walking up we're we're walking
up to point doom ah
we're walking all the way up and she's
walking in front of me the whole time
i'm like [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] dude
you're not gonna do it like why the [ __ ]
are you you talking to her no in my head
oh yeah i said that to her first and
then also saying that you're not gonna
say yes this guy yeah how long were you
together or why would she why wouldn't
you not i don't know dude i don't know
why i was nervous you know like you guys
are hardest high school sweethearts and
you're still thinking she's gonna say no
yeah dude
but no but still like it is like nerve
like you're still nervous you thought
she was gonna say no you i i was like
she's most likely gonna say yes
but in your head you have to
you have to prep yourself no matter what
because we were at the edge of a
mountain so i was like i know my
contingency plan i was going to throw
her off and i was going to join she said
no well i didn't like you anyway [ __ ]
i would jump off right after after but
yeah i was nervous same thing i was like
shaking and i was like stuttering i got
on one knee
and then she's like why are you such a
[ __ ] you know what she said to me she
goes i can't believe you got on one knee
that's what she said and then she goes
while you did it
she was like one little piss yeah she's
like you're gonna be on the knee you
little puss that's what she's saying
like we tried to set my dick way down
was she really shocked about that yeah
because you wouldn't do that normally
well she she just didn't think i was
going to because i guess i had i made it
she usually sucks her dick on two knees
yeah i made i made a joke about like i'm
not getting on one knee or some [ __ ]
like that i think i think that's what it
was but she just was she took it
seriously or i think it was it was
either that or the fact that she just
didn't think i was gonna do it for some
weird reason you have to ask her i have
no idea
she's a loser dude i can't wait for this
guy to propose me yeah i can't wait
because the chick will pick you up and
she'll be psyched
you know she's going to propose to me
through the ring i'm a modern man
i'm a modern man i want a woman in
charge she's going to pick me up and
suck me off after
she's going to take you home she's going
to walk dip me bro she's going to
[ __ ] pick me up she'll walk you
through the [ __ ] uh door front door
your dad's going to walk you up to her
that's right
oh yeah you're gonna ask my family for
pleasure yeah you'd be like hey dad will
you give me away and you're done
yeah sure
holds in the same way passes him can
they carry me across like this passes
and passes you make my own rules up [ __ ]
that bro
i actually have video of her carrying me
in the pool and [ __ ] tulum like this
like i was a [ __ ] damsel in distress
today's video is brought to you by
draftkings draftkings the number one
leader in fantasy sports is putting you
in the middle of the action to get a
chance of winning millions of dollars in
total prizes especially during this
football season man they're giving out
millions of dollars in prizes every
freaking week this is crazy and it's
pretty easy to participate all you got
to do is download draftkings and enter
the football daily fantasy contests did
i mention millions of prizes but you
gotta make sure you put in the promo
code off the record it's super easy to
do too you get to pick nine players
your tight end your defense your flex
player your wide receiver it's got to
make sure that the total salary cap is
in over 50 g's and you rack up points
for touchdowns total yards and field
goals and so much more and what's cool
about this is like yeah fantasy football
is fun
and you know but when you can win some
millions of prizes that makes it even
more funner in my opinion oh yeah
millions of dollars in total prizes
which is freaking awesome download the
draftkings app and don't forget to use
the code off the record to get a chance
of winning millions of dollars in total
prizes that's the code off the record
and don't forget to download the
draftkings app and it's not just for
football they got it for all kinds of
sports so you can find a sport that you
like too do you have wedding plans now
or what's going on because the pandemic
did you do it in hawaii too did you
propose on a while i didn't i didn't
propose online he proposed on stage yeah
yeah there's the whole thing remember oh
yeah it wasn't written by it i remember
so yeah we weren't careful we're invited
[ __ ] out of here dude
he did a social media opportunity if you
remember it was a deep pandemic time and
i was allowed a limited number of people
to be invited let's go dude [ __ ] us
right cynical way i can describe it we
weren't careful boys yeah we're off the
record and you guys weren't on the
record you know you were off of it i
don't i don't even know if i was in town
but i heard i heard that you're i heard
that your fiance in all honesty i heard
that your fiance had the second place
treatment which i think is really nice
what's that mean oh she has a second
place dancer oh oh my god dude i thought
she was being treated second place no no
ryan what was your review of his
proposal it was actually really nice as
a winner
[ __ ] dope because i didn't know
either i thought he just i thought he
was [ __ ] oh my god
as a winner critique
yeah like look at this
both you guys are here you know
was anthony's fiance staring at the
quest direction the whole time or
oh [ __ ] god damn it dude she was just
like they're like dancing but she kept
like staring at the quest
the quest wasn't even the room but she
knew where they were north by northwest
like mecca north by north quest
she was like this little dog
that's your hand signal by the way just
for you [ __ ] delete he goes yes and
holds anthony and looks straight into
the eyes of ryan to me
and ryan's like what are you looking
about what why
no it was great i didn't know you were
gonna do that at all
i thought it was just gonna be another
hey man if i was there i think i would
have loved it too no dude if i was there
i don't boo do you know what i mean
i've been live booing the whole thing
get out while you can
get some real noodles in here huh
it was it looked really cute
who's the most romantic [ __ ] in
this room probably anthony
really yeah
yeah steve for sure dude he probably
would have proposed on the blockchain
because tiff was like i don't think
anything's gonna get on one knee so she
already expected has low expectations
yeah you ain't romantic if she thinks if
you pull up in short shorts and a fanny
pack to your proposal i was wearing
sweats sir okay
even i know that [ __ ] dog and i ain't
romantic it was supposed to you know
what what the setting was was the
setting was we're gonna go on a hike so
he couldn't dress too good yeah i was
gonna wear a suit she would be like oh
something's up hiking but that would
have been really funny though if i had a
suit like let's go hiking in a boat
you couldn't go up and look at like a
penguin on a hike you know with [ __ ]
suede shoes yeah
you want to know an amazing and
sentimental essence that came from my
proposal let me see if i can find the
text message hold on say it dude this
was gonna make our [ __ ] ball smell
right now
wait is that a good thing or a bad thing
that means all the testosterone is going
to leave our [ __ ] system
okay good
our ball is going to homogenize my [ __ ]
wait i'm going to find it i'm going to
find this text message it's going to be
amazing all sterile all across
[ __ ] now i can't find did you propose
over text your [ __ ]
he's like check your phone all right
i sent you something i'm an airdrop
right here what did you say i gotta take
some notes from this dude no no no this
this is this is a byproduct of the
proposal but i just wanted to share this
because this man is in the room and i
wanted to be very honest moment okay
after my proposal ryan texts me oh you
sweetheart ryan is a sweetheart bro you
already know the the masterfulness of
his ability to play piano and it's not
something that's like a joke it's very
beautiful i don't remember what i said
[ __ ] good yeah literally text me the
next day he goes congrats on the
engagement my friend this is just my
formal offer to do piano at your wedding
at whatever capacity you want
well done on that proposal
wow and ryan didn't even talk about it
but ryan didn't add his rates because
he's a professional dude you know what i
mean so he was going to hit him with the
bill after the wedding and he's like yo
dude
dude cut to the wedding though ryan's
like
come
don't [ __ ] me dude that was my good
improv skills on piano don't [ __ ] me
dude
that was my space work on piano don't
[ __ ] with that ryan only knows how to
play element
only space jam soundtrack you know how
important my improv skills are to me
dude come on
look we all know we all know via jk
party bryan's skills on piano are
bar none phenomenal underplays
everything this [ __ ] game also on uh
on an improv level he ain't like uh i'm
gonna [ __ ] talk amazing [ __ ] about
you while singing but the point is he
can take a song [ __ ] amazing so crazy
can like jazzify it but then he can also
like disco it yeah disco rocky
he could take like jurassic park theme
song and make it into a [ __ ] trance
song or [ __ ] take it into a [ __ ]
death metal this is like the it's like a
avatar the last genre bender of piano
type [ __ ] right so so we had asked ryan
at one point to come to uh it was our
kindest anniversary slash what we
inevitably would not discover would be
the closing of our complex at the same
time and so we had asked him at our
10-year anniversary to
compile uh a medley
of like notable kindred songs just like
some of our most viral songs that we had
choreographed or danced to that like you
know we either on tv had sentimental
value to our hardcore fans from the
origin or whatever
and he literally puts his [ __ ]
composition this medley together of like
intense like sickest smash mouth songs
[ __ ] yeah she was like that's like 15
minutes long
yeah it's like you just didn't know
you're an all-star like the uber stay
you know how sick he is
dolph mistake smash mouth iris google
dolls but anyways
don't take away a skill the best which i
also love by the way
you all know how beautiful this guy [ __ ]
is and how quality it is
so for him to take the most iconic songs
of our entire history and put together
in like 15 minute medley and play it at
our like 10 year anniversary slash grand
opening
literally
i if i was a [ __ ] i would have been
moved to tears but i wasn't a [ __ ] i
was very strong masculine man
so i almost teared but the point is i
would have cheered it was one of the
most amazing and beautiful things that a
friend has ever done and okay but that's
not a real tribute because it should
have been just footsteps
it's like you guys made those songs like
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
footsteps
like swishes of shirts
[ __ ] tons of footsteps like but like to
the song sure stop talking about how big
this dude's dick is like
is it cool to just move on to a new
concept yeah steve you've got a small
dick bro [ __ ] you yeah we gotta start
shredding
i mean
average that's like one second like an
average dig like average dixie you gotta
advertise dicks dude imagine imagine
though like like even just imagine that
he plays imagine on piano it's like
that's our [ __ ] kid just like bro
come on
play the footsteps
that's pretty funny though
he's representing the old nike coming
you guys [ __ ] compose the badges how
touchy could it be dude i'll make you a
formal offer nina's gonna say no
guaranteed i'll play drums at your
wedding you ain't invited anymore yeah
hey dude i'll roast you at your wedding
are you down
you'll roast me at my wedding that's i'm
first you're down
unfortunate
oh my god that's sick that's fun just
for you man
that's a way heavier you have hella
aunties and uncles looking at you like
they don't get any of it they're getting
roasted too dude yeah nobody's safe
and then right after that is the job
monkey's performance yeah yeah
by careful boys yeah followed by quest
crew nina's gonna leave you by the end
of the night dude that's gonna be crazy
he was for sure leaving me the day
before good damn those sexy hot boys
with the masks are here
you guys are dicks
we can't wait for your wedding dude oh
it's gonna be lit but you have a date
yet yes you better put the careful boys
in one table dude yeah the table outside
dog and you and you have a chair there
okay
you know what i can offer a chair at the
campfire i'll be a server at your
wedding dude
i'll be a server you'll be a server i'm
a good johnny
i'll make milkshakes okay
hey i know i'm i'm in the service
industry my current work is in the
services i find joe's the officiate
and i'll serve you know your sous-vide
steaks or whatever nick is the guy who's
like he's like preparing a salad and
then anthony says something he's like
let's go and then the other the head
server goes like we don't do that and
he's like oh sorry yeah yeah
what's that what's nick doing at your
wedding tossing
salad bro
you